[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
We'll be talking about
Interesante.
Did I get that right?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yep.
Perfect.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
let me introduce
our hosts and guests.
In the studio, I have
Jeremy Walker.
How are you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm doing
pretty well.
I'm doing pretty well.
How are you doing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm doing good.
I think I am quite excited that
we have this show up and
running now that we
had some technical
difficulty getting started.
JEREMY WALKER: A couple
technical difficulties, yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
And then on my left,
Antonio Altamirano.
How are you doing, Antonio?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Good.
Good.
Thank you.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then, in the studio, we
also have Jochen Kumm.
JOCHEN KUMM: Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Great to be here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then, we will have Pablo
Gamboa joining us live as well
on the Hangout from Argentina.
Can you hear us, Pablo?
PABLO GAMBOA: Yeah.
Perfect.
Hi Jarek.
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
PABLO GAMBOA: Nice to be here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So let's get started.
So Antonio, tell us a little
bit about your company.
How did you come up with the
idea and what is the problem
you're trying to solve?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Well first,
thank you very much for
having us here.
It's a very, very exciting
to be here.
The idea of Interesante came
from the fact that we saw a
major, major need for the Latino
market in the US and in
Latin America to be served by
a tool that is culturally
sensitive and culturally
aware, as well as
geographically aware.
So we all used the tools that
are out there for social
networking.
And what we were lacking is
that connection to our own
culture, to where we come from
and to the things that matter
most to us Latinos and
to the way that
we communicate online.
So the tools that exist right
now work, but they don't take
into consideration the fact that
we have different needs
in terms of communication and
in terms of interest.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hence
the name, Interesante?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: My Spanish
isn't all that good but I
figured that one out.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yeah.
Yes.
So Interesante comes
into the picture.
It's an evolution of
a prior product.
So what we did is we wanted to
share our interests, our
favorite quotes online.
So we started just developing
this and we realized that a
lot of people were coming in
and connecting with what we
were doing because we were
targeting this particular
population.
We were doing it for us,
and a lot of people
connected with that.
So we saw this, but the brand
name did not make a lot of
sense at that point.
It was called Proverbio and it
was too narrow of a set.
So what we did is we were
thinking about a word that
will unite interest across
South America.
So what we wanted to do is we
wanted a word that is easy to
understand, it's playful, and
is understood by everyone.
Because people that are watching
this show, they will
know that there are many
differences between the
Spanish that is spoken in
Argentina versus the Spanish
that is spoken in Mexico, but
the word interesante brings
all of that together.
So that is what we stand for.
We want to be the place where
Latinos can find their
interests online
and on mobile.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds like
you performed a proverbial
pivot and became Interesante.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Very interesting history.
So I was thinking, perhaps,
rather than describing in
words of what the product does,
maybe you could give us
a little demo?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yes.
Completely.
Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure.
Maybe we'll--
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO:
I would love to.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
--try the demo.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Great.
So this is the landing page
and I want to show you the
landing page so that there
are a few steps--
Interesante is very
easy to use.
So basically what you have to do
is you have to create your
account and you start to see
this interests that are
relevant to you.
So as you roll over, you see
this button that says mi
interessa and if you're
interested in that interest,
then you click and we classify
it automatically.
So and you can see that the
collection is automatically
set and that we categorize
that collection.
So you can select from a wide
variety of interest.
And here you can see that
Android is very popular in
Latin America so that's a very
popular item in Interesante as
well as travel for places that
are not found in sites like
Expedia or anything like that.
This is just very localized type
of travel that this is
growing exponentially
in Latin America.
Then with that--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if you
want to find a destination
that isn't popular yet but
it's cool, you go to
[INAUDIBLE]
Interesante.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
Yes.
Exactly.
So then with that, we take that
and we Johen here that
will speak more about that, but
we have algorithms that,
as I said, they're culturally
aware and we help you discover
new interests.
So for instance, if because I
am into Interesante, then I
see this mug with the logo
of Interesante on it.
And also, as an addition to
that, you can collect them.
So you can collect this interest
and you can select
your own collection, but the
point here is that we don't
want people to be worrying too
much about what they have to
do, where they have to put it,
so we built the intelligence
in the back-end and we take
your interests we auto
categorize them, and we use
that so that we can serve
better interests to you.
And of course, we're
in mobile as well.
And we'll be showing
that later.
If you want, I'm going to go
really quickly to one of the
actual screenshots
of the product.
So for instance, this is an
interest that many people--
this is in Spanish so basically
it says that these
are not bags under
my eyes, they're
just accumulated ideas.
That's perfect for you.
So you see that eight people
have collected that.
You have access to those
people, but most
interestingly, you have access
to all the interests that
relate to that particular
thing.
So and we're doing the
same with video.
So again, this is something
that is very popular.
This is Sofia Vergara is very
popular in our site.
I hope we're live there now.
Let me talk about the
integration with YouTube, in
particular.
Let me just get to the right
URL so that I can share.
OK.
So in this case, we have this
video that basically talks
about how difficult it is
to understand Spanish.
So it goes through like 10
different words and explains
the different meanings in
different countries.
So this also supports the fact
that we need a place where we
can collect our common interest,
not only our
differences.
So what we did is we integrated
with YouTube and
you can see all of this
recommendations that we get
directly from YouTube.
And the moment that you click
on one of them, then it
creates another interest on
Interesante so that you
continue to build your database
of interest that is
personal to you and we can do
a better job at suggesting
things to you proactively.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And that is using the Topic API
that we'll talk about a
little later--
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --with
Pablo about.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then, you also have
a mobile app, right?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Correct.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Actually we
tried to look at the mobile
app as well.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yeah.
So what we did in the mobile
app is we wanted to have a
different utility because mobile
is such a different
platform that we wanted to make
it quick for our users to
be able to find their
interests.
So for instance, right now we're
in the category section
and what we do is we take into
consideration the activity
that you have and we
suggest interests.
For instance, what we're showing
right now on the
screen, is their entertainment
category and you can just
swipe through all of them and
see what's interesting to you
and what is not interesting
to you as well.
So in the top right hand corner,
you'll see a counter.
So that counter just basically
tell you, hey, you've done
this much today and we're going
to tell you how you
stand versus other users.
So you can also discover
other users as well.
But mainly what we focus on is
what is interesting to people
and through that, it is a
channel for discovering
interests more than
people themselves.
So you remove a lot of the
friction between who is the
person who is recommending me.
We're going directly into what
is interesting to the people.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the idea
here is I may have many
different interests and someone
may not be all that
interested in me, but they
might be interested in a
particular area that I'm--
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --collecting
information about or may be
curating videos and so forth.
Right?
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So then they
would actually follow that.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And just
subscribe to it.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: And the
cool thing is that I don't
have to actually go to
your profile and
choose what I like.
The system will tell me, oh,
because you like add
technology or because you like a
certain topic and because of
your activity, then we're going
to take one of your
interests and suggest it to
[INAUDIBLE] for instance.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: So then
it's built in within this
discovery and the experience
of the app.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So now I know Jochen works on
figuring out exactly the
mathematics behind the interest
accommodations and
then we also have Pablo on the
Hangout so why don't we talk a
little bit more about the
technical aspects of this
integration.
Let's see if we can bring
in Pablo online here.
JEREMY WALKER: Can you
hear us, Pablo?
Great.
Can you talk a little bit about
how the integration with
the app came about?
PABLO GAMBOA: Well something
Antonio said, our man use of
the YouTube API was to get
related media on Interesante.
And the user has the opportunity
to create
interests with YouTube videos.
So when another user opens the
video on Interesante, what we
have done is to comb YouTube's
API and also use the Freebase
topics that they provide to get
related videos that we can
recommend to that user.
So this provides the users with
a lot of more content
that maybe interesting
for him.
And also, with just a couple
of clicks, the user can add
those new YouTube related videos
to his collection on
Interesante.
So it's like we are having
two features.
One is recommendations and the
other is letting the user add
this content to his interests
[INAUDIBLE].
That feature is live on
Interesante.com now, and we
have another feature that is
still in beta, we are still
working on it which is basically
the possibility to
import your playlist, uploaded
videos, favorites [INAUDIBLE]
from your YouTube account or
from another [INAUDIBLE]
account.
But this is still beta.
We don't have this feature
on production right now.
JEREMY WALKER: So let's go back
a little bit because you
said something that I'm
really interested in.
Our new version of the data API,
which launched recently
and Jarek posted it, uses one
of the new features is the
Topic's API which uses Freebase
a little bit.
So I know, and we want to get
into this with you, if you
could talk a little
bit about that.
So it sounds like you're
importing and you're using
that portion of the data API to
kind of get recommendations
from other people and kind
of categorize them.
Is that correct?
PABLO GAMBOA: Yeah,
that's correct.
Technically, what we are doing
is once we tapped the video we
get the video in and we query
the API to get topics related
from Freebase [INAUDIBLE]
release that [INAUDIBLE].
And once we get that topics,
with our [INAUDIBLE]
we find which topics we are
going to get to use and then
query again the API to get
those related videos.
So it's pretty important to
query that Freebase topic now.
JEREMY WALKER: And did you want
to add anything to that
because I know you really
jump into the
details of all that stuff?
JOCHEN KUMM: Yeah, I'll talk
about the algorithms without
talking about the algorithms.
I think when I came to
Interesante that the question
was, is there something unique
about Latinos, in the most
general sense?
Having lived there, I think
I know there is, but the
question was can we capture
that and what's the point?
So the idea was you have
two extremes here.
You can go and look at everybody
in the world and try
to understand everybody
in the world.
What happens is you lose
your resolution.
On the other extreme today, you
can probably track someone
as a person and get to know them
very well but that wasn't
what we were after because we
want to show them, we bring
them into the world.
So Interesante is right
in the middle.
We're trying to find the
community that you're part of
so you don't have to look at the
whole world and just get
lost, but you're not limited
to your own little world.
So we are about finding Latino
communities that emerge
naturally from the data.
And so one more point here, we
have two things going on.
We have algorithms that create
communities algorithmically by
standard Markov-based
sampling algorithms.
And there's an interesting
phenomenon which I want to
think Pablo for and the whole
Interesante team, the
interface is designed
and it was working.
So in addition to algorithmic
community, we have
self-organizing communities
in Interesante.
And it is just a wonderful sort
of in order out of chaos
emerging in Interesante.
From an algorithmic point
of view, lots of people
interested in self-organizing
community and Interesante is a
great example for it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So are you
modeling that in your basement
right now with Markov
chains and such?
JOCHEN KUMM: Yeah, yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This show
amazes me because it's been a
long time since I had to read
about Markov chains and this
was not my favorite
topic in school.
JOCHEN KUMM: But it's so cool.
Well I'm really getting to
know Latinos [INAUDIBLE]
Mexico and the United States
and finding out what their
communities are and they're
very diverse.
I mean, we've had Guatemalan
writers, schoolteachers, the
Red Cross, everybody stepping
in, self-organizing, and then
we can support them behind the
scenes with our algorithms
which is sort of a socially
aware way of using algorithms.
And hopefully we can do some
statistical something that
makes a difference.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: And just
to add something, you
mentioned the Red Cross.
So the Red Cross right
now is in Mexico.
They have these great
videos about social
responsibility, basically.
But they didn't have a good
way to get the word out.
So they're using
us to do that.
And the advantages that by using
the integration that we
have with YouTube and their own
videos, they don't focus
only in one video, in one
message, they have an audience
that comes in and then they
see that there are other
relevant topics that they can
learn about that is related to
the Red Cross and what they're
doing in Mexico.
And there's a lot going
on in Mexico--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: --that is
being communicated via video
and what is lacking
is a good platform
that connects everyone--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO:
--culturally.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think we talked about that
about pivoting earlier on this
show and I think that one of
the ways in which I see you
using the API is that by user
sharing the video, you can
actually find what's related and
have them actually explore
things that maybe they
didn't know existed--
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --and this
uses the Topic's API and then
the Freebase on the back-end
to figure out all the terms
that might be related.
JOCHEN KUMM: Yeah.
Freebase is pretty amazing.
It gives us a look into the
whole world and it made our
algorithmic development so much
faster because that's our
starting point and refining is
much easier than trying to
build Freebase from scratch
so we love Freebase.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do you find
that Freebase's coverage of
the Latin America Spanish terms
this is adequate for
your use case?
JOCHEN KUMM: In a way I have to
say the Latino community is
under-served a little bit.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
JOCHEN KUMM: So what we're
finding is in addition to
switching existing content,
Interesante is continuously
creating content that wasn't
on the web before.
So that is not in Freebase yet
and we'll have to figure out
ways to ultimately
bring back to the
community what we are gathering.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm sure that
the Freebase folks will
be happy to have it.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
They'd love to hear
about that.
But just quick, to jump back in
the technical end, Pablo,
can you tell us a little bit,
if you can, about--
I'm always curious what you
used on the back-end, what
language you actually used to
do your implementation.
PABLO GAMBOA: Well I can brief
you something about our
technical aspect.
In the back-end, we are using
like three different
[INAUDIBLE].
We are using PHP and Python for
the main core of the web
application and our API that
uses the application and also
the iPhone application
that you've seen.
And we are also using Ruby
on Rails for our
recommendation engine.
And everything is connected
to MySQL in database.
And that's for the
back-end now.
The front end is pretty simple,
a lot of Javascript,
jQuery precisely.
And we are using Twitter
[INAUDIBLE]
framework also up front.
So that's the main thing which
is that we are using now.
The decision to use these
languages are related to the
way that we work.
It's a lean start-up that's
how we define us.
We always try to move quickly
on implementation and try to
deliver fast to the production
server so that's what we are
using right now.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
I'm always curious, did you have
any surprises when you
were integrating with
the YouTube API?
Anything that you weren't
expecting?
I'm always just curious
when you were
integrating with our APIs.
PABLO GAMBOA: I don't if
surprise is the word, but we
were really happy because it
was really simple for us to
understand and incubate
[INAUDIBLE].
I mean, as I told you, we try
to work fast and try to
deliver fast what
we are doing.
And I think the main feature for
recommendations went very
well, went pretty quick, and
that's because the API is
really intuitive.
And also the [INAUDIBLE]
of the new API is
also excellent.
You have examples there.
You have all you need to know so
it was really simple for us
to do that and in a
really short time.
So that was surprising for us.
I mean, something that you
think that may be will be
difficult to do was
very simple.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
great to hear.
That's great to hear.
Do you have any features that
you wish were part of the API?
Like anything on
your wish list?
PABLO GAMBOA: I think that
it's pretty complete now.
I was checking all the other
features that we didn't use
yet and it's pretty complete.
I would like to see how it's
going to be more integrated
with Freebase.
That is really important
for us.
That's more.
JEREMY WALKER: So deeper
integration with Freebase.
PABLO GAMBOA: Yeah.
Deeper integration with that.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
All right.
So let's check to
see we have any
questions in the moderator.
I see one question that I think
might be addressed at
you, Jeremy.
And the question is, is YouTube
Developer operations hiring?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
We're always hiring.
Specifically for the YouTube
team too so if you're
interested in video, you know
coding, check out our site.
It's on
developers.google.com/jobs.
So check that out and even if
you're not interested in
YouTube, we have a bunch of
positions even outside of that
that are available.
So please check that out.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
I think this is it.
Thank you very much for joining
us today live in the
studio and thank you,
Pablo for joining
us live on the Hangout.
And we'll see you live next
time, same time 10:00 AM
Pacific, Wednesdays on YouTube
Developers Live.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
Thank you.
ANTONIO ALTAMIRANO: Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Bye.
JOCHEN KUMM: Later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]